[Music]
[Applause]
is mark sanchez going to join us he's on
the line right now as we speak oh he is
okay
hi mark the uh fox analyst and uh former
nfl quarterback and at usc um great to
talk to you we wanted to talk to you
about
uh ryan tannehill's comments let me play
it and then i'll get your thoughts i
thought i was here for cinco de mayo oh
sanchez okay my bad my bad as pretzy
said we need sanchez on cinco de mayo
wow that's so not necessary mark sanchez
i'm sorry my feelings
i'm sorry i think i think mark said he's
sorry about that yeah sorry about that
was this was this a token interview wow
[Music]
i am so sorry mark that i didn't know
that fritzi you know that this was a
token interview do you celebrate cinco
de mayo okay do you do
celebrate no it's more of a um it's
honestly become more of an american
holiday and i had to look this up years
ago but
uh mexican independence day is like
september 15th i want to say because uh
they always have like big fights like
canelo and oscar de la hoya they would
always fight around then
big big time for a lot of people to
travel from mexico to vegas and so it
makes sense to have a big fight that
time think of the miles just one battle
it's the you know remembrance or
whatever of one battle
in which they beat the spanish or
something like that but it's not like
like you go to mexico today it's not
like some crazy you know shut down the
banks in the post office we're all gonna
party and celebrate it's not like fourth
of july down there today all right mark
thank you that's all we wanted to talk
to you about
[Music]
okay uh
marv can you play ryan tannehill's
comments this is a portion of his
comment okay
we're competing against each other we're
uh you know watching the same take we're
doing the same drills i don't think it's
my job to mentor him but you know if he
learns learn from me along the way then
then that's a great thing
okay you've been a starter you were a
backup
the role that you play as a starter the
role that you hope to play as a backup
so i think your answer yesterday dan and
i that's that's what prompted this whole
thing not my heritage uh in coming on
the show it's um
the way you answer the question i don't
think anybody's answered it that well
because if you actually say yes or no to
the question it's a total loaded
question right you're screwed either way
yeah and
if you say yes it's my job to mentor him
and i'm happy to do it
whether it's true or not you just sound
like a complete pushover and a total
wuss and like you know the fans are like
oh okay well he's ready to pass the
baton that's great what a nice guy
and your teammates are kind of like what
like what's that all about
what happened to the dog that was with
us like
in this battle like where's our guy you
know maybe he lost his stinger maybe he
doesn't care anymore you know it just
leaves a lot of room for doubt and
leaves you open
now if you say no
then you're just a complete [ __ ] like
oh my gosh i can't believe he wouldn't
do that what a villain you know what a
jerk
and
it's really
you know
it's it's really not your job
but the way you answered it yesterday
when you said listen if he can learn
from me
that means i'm doing something right
that means i'm helping the team that
means we're getting first downs we're
you know i'm i'm orchestrating
scoring drives
and if he gleans a little bit off of me
in my study habits that help me play
well on the field then that's great
but you don't really
the problem is the reporters and and
people are savvy enough to ask this
question because it's a total setup
and guys
you know they get caught off guard they
shouldn't now you know as publicized as
this one is from here on out like you
don't have to answer the question you
don't have to say yes or no
take it wherever you want to go
but
don't say yes or no because it just it
it brings along so much
negativity with it and
it's really too bad for those guys but
when you're the backup
you know you're
you're fighting like hell to get on the
field and that's the thing like there's
only one guy who plays it's only one
quarterback on the field
and
it's different you got five other wide
outs that are rotating in and out you
got multiple defensive ends you got
multiple defensive linemen and offensive
linemen that kind of shuffle in and out
it's just different it's the nature of
the position is different
and so when you draft a guy that's
potentially going to take your spot
that makes life a little uneasy i mean i
was there in new york with you know with
gino smith we went through that
um you know i'm behind nick foles after
he has this amazing season in philly
like i've been on both sides of it and
it's
it's uh it's definitely uncomfortable um
i gotta say that every time i was
professional um you know i
did my best to be cool i'm not gonna
like sabotage the guy but i'm not gonna
go out of my way to like
help him
uh or you know unless it's unless you
don't feel threatened i guess
right if there's no threat like what is
aaron rodgers worried about with you
know
the guy behind him with jordan love you
know he's giving him tips and hey here's
how i throw this ball and
blah blah blah move your feet like this
when you throw the quick little bubble
screen it'll get your hips open and give
you an easy lane to throw it or whatever
but a lot of those things you just start
to learn by watching the other guy
yeah and i think that you
if you do your job as the starter the
backup can then watch you do it but also
he can ask you questions i don't think
ryan tannehill you know at the end of a
game is going to go uh hey malik come on
over here let me tell you all the great
things that i did he doesn't have time
exactly right he doesn't have time to do
that other quarterbacks and in really
even other uh sports do we say oh you're
gonna mentor that guy it's only that
position that that exactly that sport
exactly you gotta mentor this guy
and i agree with you if ryan tannehill
didn't put himself in this position then
they'd probably be talking about a
contract extension and they wouldn't be
drafted blake willis right
100 although he did fall kind of in
their lap but all these things had to
happen to get to here right he had to
throw three interceptions in that you
know divisional game and they were
ranked number one and or the top seed or
whatever you know so all those things
had to happen for them to even be
sniffing around and maybe they would
have drafted this kid anyway because he
fell so far
but still it wouldn't feel like such a
threat without that game last year and
then you put them in this position and
as long as listen as long as you're
professional
because they say is it your job to
mentor right you got to go back to the
question what's the actual question
is it your job to mentor him well no the
answer is flat out no
the answer is
you know
my job is to win football games okay now
break that down well we gotta complete
passes i gotta get us into the right
play i gotta get us out of negative
plays
and
we gotta kick the ball after every
series either a punt an extra point or a
field goal and if we're doing that and
i'm taking care of the football and
throwing touchdowns and stuff
yeah that's my job to move the team down
the field the offensive team down the
field and score points and beat the
other team that's my job all right i i
want to ask you about name image and
likeness we're a little short on time
here i want to know that the downside if
there is of name image and likeness
well right now i guess it's just kind of
not real rules i i heard something about
some tasks
assembled you know the avengers are
getting assembled to uh
come up with some rules around here
because guys you know you hear these
stories of guys players you know
flipping their commitment and
alliance from one school to another
based on guaranteed money for name image
and likeness
and you know it's turning into this like
bidding war for players as much as some
coaches and players want to deny it
that's what it is and the fact of the
matter is this stuff's been going on for
a long time now it's just like you know
it's it's like uh
it's like marijuana right like all of a
sudden marijuana is legal okay and
people are like oh sweet except for the
people who've been smoking for like a
really long time like they don't really
care so this stuff has been happening
like if you're telling me players
haven't been paid
for a long time like that's crazy now
they're just making it okay and now
they're trying to figure out okay where
what are the rules we put on this
because this thing's spiraling out of
control and who's really in charge
what's really going on
and so you know if you put some task
force on it usually that means
things aren't going well you're you're
leaking oil somewhere and so somebody's
going to try and fix it
but i don't know i don't know what what
they're gonna do who's the first person
to get in trouble
for offering money you know the ncaa is
already on thin ice they don't wanna
they don't wanna come down on one of
these players and make an example of
someone like they tried with reggie bush
like it's just gonna backfire because
people are questioning their authority
as it is
it's always great to talk to you mark we
appreciate you joining us and listening
to the program and uh we'll talk soon
love you guys talk soon that's martin
sanchez yes happy cinco de mayo a token
interview by fritzy